siamo andati da sky l'altro giorno per
fare delle pro mont social face siamo
andati in due programmi il primo era con
diletta leotta
vi lascio al video secondo me merita
[Musica]
bravi ragazzi ma che ci fate qui state
palleggiando nel mio studio visto come
lo mettiamo in ordine le cose ma volete
fare una gara di palleggi per caso io
faccio l'arbitro ma anche se tu mi
sembravi meno prepararsi per come lo
faccio l'arbitro si ma coi tacchi lo fai
facciamo che dovete contare quanti
palleggi fate ok impedimento sono i
tacchi lo facciamo che spalletti con del
ghiaccio in busta tre manche nelle quali
ci sfideremo noi due
guardo io poi pronti che poi si perde
pure noi c'è tra questo è preso
ispirazione social facebook 15 parte c'è
la penitenza però non stai contando 2
bene era difficile da ricordarci trento
con 316 contando 2 dai un altro paio
ricordare ma quindi adesso qual è la
sconfitta cosa deve pagare ripagare
pegno e la penney temporeggiare un
peperoncino con il mio zio umberto
veniva la calabria su grossi così è
bello social facetime io vado a
prenderlo io il peperoncino regalarti 43
quando ma perché riga
[Musica]
oggi abbiamo detto peperoncino e un menù
ricco vasto consigliere geranio tutto si
ma domani anche tu a me piace a tutti
gli occhi ma questo però se no sei tu
che vuoi vai che uomo ragazzi che uomo
anzi insieme tutti i giorni alimenti e
guanti sono stati veloci tolgono e così
ora vittime ragazzi in bocca al lupo per
fare al paese soprattutto per questo
peperoncino lo vorrei essere voi adesso
che c'è inizia con di gente sicuramente
starete pensando marce siete andati da
sky quindi perché non fare una promo
seria tranquilla spieghiamo bene come se
non facciamo i soliti pirla e la
risposta di sky è stata ma anche
ma anche no nella nuova canzone dei punt
hellas vi lascio il link in descrizione
per andare a vedere il videoclip che è
una bomba e ipantellas non mi hanno mica
chiesto di fare questa promo la faccio
io in modo genuino comunque bene jacopo
avete azzeccato perché mi sa che questa
è la colonna sonora della mia vita e di
un sacco di persone che mi seguono credo
quindi ragazzi nel video di pan della
sin descrizione andata scrivere nei
commenti mi manda favi jericho seeley
tempestiamo di commenti sotto
così imparano a non invitarmi nel loro
videoclip perché qua tutti amici amici e
poi ti rubano le fiji che direi che
possiamo passare alla seconda promo che
abbiamo fatto sempre su sky che era un
po più articolata rivola di prima buona
visione
prego accomodatevi certo si subito visto
che siete dei patiti di giochi io vi
propongo subito un bel quick vicine ma
ci state
sì però cosa questi sono degli intrugli
particolari chiaramente analcolici che
vi ho preparato apposta chi risponde
giusto non beve per far vedere
parto subito con la prima domanda qual è
il titolo dell'ultimo film di steven
spielberg no reni player one bravo
questo qui mi faccio il cavo cavallo
andati con tulli alla doccia cavallo da
solo e che esso tantissimo questa era
troppo facile come domanda quindi
alziamo un pochino livello di difficoltà
servono domanda ha vinto un oscar e
diretto una serie con sharon stone dai
tutor gigi d'alessio
bello questo però dovete avere tutte e
due ben organizzate 11 deve essere
cattivo vendiamolo uguale no no no un
brindisi analcolico by alla salute direi
però non riguarda anche il mio ma si
vede che io ho delle papille gustative
cosa fare ma io ho sentito l'odore di
morte chiunque ve lo dico che era era
steven soderbergh e la serie si chiama
mosaique e oltretutto la mia seconda
risponde certo
terza domanda è unix man diventato
famosissimo sguardo aspetta hugh jackman
ma non va però non mi ha fatto venire
qui adesso bene di esattori statuto
voglio finire di parlare in famosissimo
finire oratorio cos'è cambiato lo staff
è comunque a questo punto finisco la
domanda è un ex limita al famosissimo
per un film in cui recitava nudo 9 noi
siamo cultori di questa cosa
bender ovviamente avete visto codice
criminale con fassbender giorno e spesso
è la risposta giusta
lo abbiamo visto questa è veramente
facilissima come si chiama il migliore
amico peloso del protagonista di solo e
star wars story e non lo so e ci becca
di casa e trova ci disse va bene ma
pretendiamo anticamente lo aspetta se
manca una domanda avuto in carriera ha
vinto io mi butto strano che sia non so
passata di pomodoro penso proprio
o ancora sentimenti contrastanti è buono
ma non è buono insomma sono brava a fare
intrugli analcolici ready sì perché non
so cosa dirti ti seguono il buono però
bisogno ma anche una domanda che ci
facciamo una domanda libano social face
è no allora nella scorsa stagione una
persona del cast si è ritrovata diciamo
a stretto contatto con un serpente e
questa persona si è un po pentita di far
parte social facebook che persona è
torna
[Musica]
che persona allora dico grada perché una
donna ed è sicuramente più coraggiosa
tipo gli uomini sbagliato un paio così
tutti no 11 che tu anche comune basta
già bevuto quella luna lei lei ma così
sentimenti contrastanti si è detto
quindi ragazzo livelli queste erano le
promo di social face
nel caso non aveste capito da lunedì al
venerdì alle 20 45 su skyuno è la cosa
che mi rende orgoglioso di questo e che
ci abbiamo messo una vita per
registrarlo
ma le puntate fanno veramente scassato
da ridere vi lascio con un piccolo
piccolissimo mash up di tutti i momenti
più figli miei di social phase iii e
niente noi ci vediamo il prossimo video
da ragazzi
[Applauso]
[Musica]
non è normale